deux biologistes montréalais ont résolu
une vieille énigme soulevé par darwin
celle des fleurs invisible
[Musique]
ce sont des explosions de couleurs de
formes et de parfums les fleurs déploie
tout un arsenal pour séduire les
pollinisateurs
pourtant certaines plantes produisent à
la fois des fleurs magnifiques mais
aussi d'autres fleurs tout petit
rabougri presque invisible ben on parle
de plérin visée parce qu'on ne les voit
pas mais sont quand même présente c'est
sûr c'est moins agréable pour nous à
l'oeil par contre pour les plantes
peuvent effectivement sur une excellente
stratégie ces fleurs presque invisible
permettent quand même à la plante de se
reproduire mais avec elle-même sans
pollinisateurs
[Musique]
ça avait piqué la curiosité de charles
darwin il ya 150 ans d'abord parce qu'il
semblait y avoir un lien avec la forme
des fleurs quand on pense à une fleur
c'est en général une fleur asymétrie
radial avec des pétales disposés en
rayons comme une roue de vélo
avec les fleurs asymétrie bilatérales
c'est un peu comme s'il y avait un
miroir au centre le côté droit est le
reflet du côté gauche
darwin soupçonnait que ce sont ces
plantes qui produisent le plus souvent
des fleurs invisible qu'on a t'elle
kleis thorgan
charles darwin avait observé quand même
quelques douzaines de spécimens avant de
faire son hypothèse qui était à l'époque
quand même beaucoup le pour le nombre de
fleurs cristaux gamme qui était observé
mais il manquait quand même
d'information afin de pouvoir vraiment
valider son hypothèse parce que les
chansons il n'était pas assez grand le
pauvrement s'assurer que c'était bien
comme pour l'ensemble des plantes à
fleurs
[Musique]
simon jolie du jardin botanique de
montréal a donc pris le relais il s'est
allié avec daniel chaude de l'université
mcgill qui s'intéresse aux fleurs
cuistot gamme depuis 40 ans de nos jours
les biologistes ont accès à des
informations sur des plantes de partout
dans le monde ensemble ils ont analysé
2500 espèces 50 fois plus que darwin
et parmi elles vous connaissez peut-être
l'impatient duquenne
divers environnements
mail impatiente n'attire pas toujours
l'attention des insectes
c'est à ce moment là qu'elle produit des
fleurs qui ne s'ouvrent pas des fleurs
clé histogramme
ces pratiques parce que s'il ya d'autres
pollinisateurs il ya d'autres
productions des fleurs ouvertes si on
veut les conducteurs orange que l'on
voit et donc elles vont s'en remettre
aux fleurs cristaux gamme et donc il
paraît que l'histogramme comme ailier
fermer les parents un échange de pollen
en les étamines et le pistil et donc
avoir reproduction sans pollinisateurs
[Musique]
les patientes n'est pas la seule simon
joly et daniel shawn ont découvert une
quarantaine de familles de plantes
capables de produire à la fois leur
flair habituel
mais aussi de minuscules flirt liste aux
gammes qui reste fermé
d'après darwin ce serait plus fréquent
chez les fleurs bilatérales comme les
orchidées parce que leurs formes
compliquer la vie des pollinisateurs on
pense que les leur asymétrie bilatérales
sont posés par moins d'espèces et à
cause que l'axé souvent au nectar ou au
pollen est plus difficile souvent les
fleurs ont un tube
des fois des fonctions plus de 3 tu es
donc ça va limiter l'accès à plusieurs
points nous à part le quai qui ont de la
difficulté à accéder justement onex corp
[Musique]
l'autre type de fleurs les fleurs
radiall sont moins sélective elle attire
une plus grande diversité d'insectes et
c'est la clé de l'énigme parce que d'une
année à l'autre la météo varie les
quantités de chaque espèce d'insecte
aussi les fleurs asymétrie radial auront
moins de difficultés à trouver quand
même un pollinisateur parmi leurs
nombreux prétendants mais les fleurs
bilatérales au moins d'options parfois
même une seule quand la perle rare n'est
pas au rendez vous elles peuvent se
reproduire avec elle même grâce à leurs
fleurs invisible
et c'est un grand avantage qu'elles ont
les pleurs d'avoir les deux sexes donc
c'est un peu comme si c'était une
assurance à la reproduction d'avoir des
parcs l'histogramme
ces travaux ont permis de confirmer les
hypothèses de darwin sur cette stratégie
plutôt surprenante c'est un processus
est quand même assez exceptionnel
on est un organe flanqué capable de
développer de deux façons bien
distinctes soit on a une forte est
complètement ouverte soit en une fleur
qui est complètement fermée et c'est le
même mécanisme qui va générer ces deux
types de fleurs donc c'est quand même un
processus génétique et pas celle qu'on
connaît pas d'ailleurs le sait pas des
choses qu'on connaît mais c'est pas
quelque chose de très simple pour a
évolué si on veut donc c'est pour ça
qu'on ne trouve pas ce seuil est
fréquemment
ses fleurs presque invisible cache donc
encore des secrets des énigmes à
résoudre pour des générations de
botanistes